hey everyone welcome back to game Sports
coverage of e3 2019 joining me Lisa
James on the couch is Mike mihari and
Jean crooks lead producer on watchdogs
leisure now this is where I as a British
person come into my own hopefully
because it's set in jolly old London
sure now how is the reveal for you
I guess what's been the reaction to the
new setting the reveal has been amazing
the feedback although all the things
we're hearing is fantastic the team were
very proud obviously the setting is
London and London's very interesting for
what slugs are the Rhine because London
being one of the most surveilled cities
in the world its culture its history
that the contrast between modern
architecture and old buildings is the
perfect playground for our characters
one thing I would say that I noticed
from that gameplay reveal is something's
very strange to me is that there are
guns in watchdogs Legion whereas
obviously guns illegal in the UK and
hopefully will continue to be so but how
did you go about introducing them as a
part of your gameplay in watchdogs
leaders so what's interesting is most
likely Jim we set London in the near
future and the near future and what
stocks we always flirt with technology
and its impact in society and in the
near future London really printing is
everywhere so everyone can print what
they want and also in London the mint
bad guys the authoritarian regime that's
taking control of London Albion is a
private military corporation so that's
how we're looking at you know an
alternate what if London and how we
could introduce that so it's said in a
post brexit world and in the voice-over
in the trailer the guy said you know the
government has abandoned us is that how
the millet that this militia kind of
gets its claws in well I think the
important thing about how we position
the world of watchdog Legion is that
there are many problems in the world
right now and we feel that we wanted to
kind of express all of them and look at
say well how would all of that
contribute to a future London and what
would it look like
so it's more that the causes of brexit
of what are the causes of the changes to
the world we watch like Legion not
necessarily that in a bit self you know
pretty early on in development it's game
that you wanted to let people be any
character or is that something that
arose out of the development process or
well
how what was that decision like so in
watchdog's we always flirted with the
profile at cards and looking into
people's lives and one of the
discussions early on in what succeeding
was what if all of that was accurate
real and simulated what if every
character we looked at how to real life
you could follow them if they had our
lunch they would go to lunch if they had
a job you could follow them to their job
and it actually worked that way and then
on top of that you could find them
recruit them and play as anyone and
that's pretty much how we do both that
was kind of what we were saying when we
first saw it during the press conference
is that kind of makes sense it's like a
natural evolution it's like the earlier
watchdog's games yeah you're looking and
seeing like these flavor text about this
random NPC it's going by you can also
maybe steal their money but now it's
almost like that you're pushing it to
its extreme and like oh you see
characters that's I need like someone
who's good with drones etc I'm gonna
recruit them they're gonna have their
own mission it feels like the natural
yet extreme evolution of the watchdog's
format I'm not allowed to do some really
cool things so every character in our
world has traits and these are gameplay
elements that you can find that might
support you and what you need to do so
you kind of look around for a cool
character say you have a drone problem
you've got to find a guy that's pretty
strong with drones and once you find
them you can look into their lives look
at their problems convince them to join
dedsec by helping them and then you have
them in your team as a fully playable
character so I mean if you're gonna be
flitting around between all these
characters how do you keep the momentum
of the storyline going what is the you
know what's the narrative thread that's
pulling you along understand the strong
core storyline and what's Allegiant is
about fighting a resistance and and one
of the strong themes you always said
it's about a group of people banding
together and fighting back so we focus
all our narrative around those those
points so we have storylines that
involve crime bosses that that's that's
taking advantage of an absence of a you
know a collapsing government and the
private military corporation also
abusing the same thing so the idea of
building a bunch of like-minded people
to fight back against that is what
really drove us so kind of playing
devil's advocate the other day when I
was saying how super ambitious and
interesting it looks and I personally
really enjoy games where there's
literally right before this moment I
said I wonder if there's permit out
these characters there's a moment where
someone's in
and the word came up playing devil's
advocate what if I'm someone who really
likes a like scripted character how why
am I gonna care about all of these
people if I can be anyone and they're
not someone that Ubisoft has spent years
just writing specifically for them as a
very coolin coolin Center that every
single character is well realized you
can literally play a cinematic with
different characters and they they have
different personalities in that
cinematic all the little nuances of how
they speak their lives they all come
through in the cinematics and the
storylines when you play with them you
really get attached to these characters
that it's amazing what's in string to me
with these kind of games let's go off in
a tangent you probably know I like
talking about these kind of games but
it's always used to me how like I get
more attached to people and kind of like
telling their story myself yeah I've got
a few character attributes I know
they're good with drones I know she's
this older woman from was about to name
some neighborhood from London with them
I don't know there's a good way thank
you so and then of these come up and I'm
like it oh I remember what I did with
her in the game I remember what he did
and it's always interesting how that
kind of storytelling gets me personally
more attached to these characters and if
they were scripted for me so yeah I mean
the cool thing about plays anyone and
looking internalizes lizzi's they create
these tiny anecdotes I have a great one
I was playing before coming here and I
and I had a character it was a an
identity thief and then the contact
listing had another identity thief and
I'm like who's the real guy he was
stealing from him here right so I went
into a full side track about figuring
out who the person which person was the
real person and who was the identity
thief so there's very cool little things
even just the system is like you play
where they allow you to do that you know
you don't see another games at all so I
mean we're looking at we're watching
Helen right now how differently all
these characters gonna play some see I
can see her kind of ambling around a
little bit moving a little bit slower I
imagine not every character is gonna
move as slowly as Helen well basically
what we wanted to do is represent the
range of how you can play fantasy you're
playing as anyone and what that means
you know from from
a grime young street kid to a to a
grandma he just kind of said you know
exposing Helen was clearly give the
players an idea of the range of all the
different personas and archetypes that
you can play within all of these
characters let's talk a little bit about
London itself so Ubisoft has this
pedigree of really going in to town on
its research when it comes to
replicating real-life places I mean I
thought that was a pond sorry oh it was
it was I was hoping just slide it out
there in terms of things like you know
Paris for Assassin's Creed unity and of
course London has been visited in
Assassin's Creed syndicate were you in
communication with the silicon team the
face that they got the map down Nathan
tweets where what was the research
process like so and Ubisoft obviously
the team start to get a lot there's a
lot of learning a lot of history that we
can pick up from each other but
obviously among London it's very
different from a classic historical in
them so you know we have to go back to
the drawing board we had to assess all
in different neighborhoods
what is crime like that what kind of guy
is is there what is the culture like is
there any cool local forever of
businesses that exist in that area we do
all this research even before we set
foot or even decide to build this city
and once we have all of that we have
this big library of information we fly
down there we spend a lot of time in the
city absorbing the culture taking
pictures and that's the best of how we
build the world Anubis often so what
what are the limits around London what
boroughs are we gonna expect succeed
Camden here we saw a sort of around
Westminster earlier Thomas is dock the
boat yes so basically it's behind fair
that's a pub of course you know London
based on from so basically we have we
have of the Tower Hamlets East yeah we
have up to booking and Palace and in the
West we go south as Brixton and
obviously as north as Camden and and
shortage can I control the Queen the
Queen is nowhere to be seen in Watford
region it's part of our backstory and
world narrative did the play as any one
system create problems when you were
building this version of London um play
as anyone is hugely ambitious and all
the systems that come into play
obviously it's a it's like something
we've never seen before but it's allowed
us to do some amazing things the things
we see you doing the anecdotes we get
from players in ourselves when when we
interact with the systems have been have
been breathtaking when it comes to him
so here we can see their you know they
talk about human trafficking yes what
stocks to had a very you know a lighter
tone you know you had this lovable band
of Mitzvahed misfits getting together
what's the tone of watchdogs Legion so
we wanted to kind of realize the you
know the oppressive state of the
authoritarian regime and what that meant
but also you know the British people
they have a great sense of humor they
live that sarcasm so we couldn't just
leave it at that so we wanted to kind of
spice it up as you see in the in the
walk through that we have Bagley our AI
assistant we've had some lovely dots of
humor into the action so you know
balancing the British humor with you
know the authoritarian tone that's
that's that was our em are we gonna get
some goods sort of fashioned London flag
there's little bits and pieces yeah
it'll might be nicer but I do wonder I
often wonder I mean it cuz I moved here
a few months ago sometimes sometimes
I'll say things that don't translate to
an American audience is that something
you have to be aware of is that British
people have a very very particular style
of humor I always struggle with saying
chips yeah I always get it wrong I don't
say fries I said chips and there's
always trunk and a herding car so
there's obviously there's a little bits
of elements and I think representing
that slang representing the local
culture it's very important to make the
game the game feel like it's pasted and
cemented in London when we saw the demo
gathered a during the Ubisoft press
conference it ended with that cut scene
between two those characters was that
the result of Ubisoft knowing which two
characters would end the presentation or
what will I see that from playing the
game so actually in any cinematic it can
be dynamic depending on who you play we
do have the villains the bad guys are
stories you will interact with those
guys but watching any character
literally any character you can find in
the world starring in your cinematics
and then watching the narrative flourish
come through based on the type of
personality that they have that that for
me is what really changes a
cinematix and works like a gym I
mentioned it earlier sorry I mentioned
it earlier and it does feel like
especially when the way you can like see
everybody's information they're out in
public that felt like a natural
evolution but the fact that you are
jumping into different people in this
series that somatically is about
surveillance and how no one has privacy
it feels like watchdogs Legion is almost
what I wanted watchdogs to be all along
through the past two games now I don't
know if that was this feeling on the dev
side of things like oh this is what
we've been wanting to make I kind of
asked earlier if it arose on a
development but does the dev team feel
like oh this is what we've been trying
to nail for X amount of years now I mean
it was always it was always in
discussion and we always chose to go
into different places but you know the
goal this time around was to literally
say we want everything that we see when
we profile someone to be real that job
is what they do you know characters or
even change plugs that when they leave
work they'll change my clothes into
different outfits it's a you know making
sure that everything that you read it
means something it attaches to their
tread and says something about what they
do in the world and then that breathes
life into the character when you recruit
them when you play them you really feel
a testicle so whenever I recruit someone
I have to kick off the kind of origin
mission is that for every single person
or just some key figures so basically
every single person in the world has a
how much they like tech tech some of
them not so much some of them are huge
fans so the goal is you have to convince
them to join the cause so what you do is
you look into their lives you analyze
what problems they might have you go fix
it for them and that kind of warms them
up to dedsec then at that point you can
kind of trigger an origin story and then
they join your team it's pretty cool I'm
curious I don't know how like accurate
or how honest for an answer you can give
but does the ambition and size this game
kind of scare you from a dev side the
most important thing for us is that we
put it on the floor to there for people
to see and watch our guys plan people
are spending a lot of time with it and
that's real it literally works like that
right now there's no smoke and mirrors
what you're seeing is what the game is
doing when we had this thing running
when we had all the technology working
and when it all all the pieces water
together it was it was a
anything disease it was such a it's such
an exciting game in like it like it's
funny like I think maybe it's just the
cynic in me I'm looking for the spot
where I'm like oh that's the catch or
that's the caveat so far I have not
found it but I'm saying like it it
almost seems like why aren't more people
doing something like this when there are
studios smaller studios doing it on a
smaller scale like state of decay does
something similar but on a much much
smaller scale but to see a big Ubisoft
studio doing it I still feel like I'm
waiting for like oh I get it that's the
smoke and mirror you mentioned so I mean
it was a car driver for us from very
early on we looked at that and said
that's exactly what we want to do so
when you are inside a very large team
around it from early days and spend
years on this kind of technology you put
a lot of effort into it but it's focused
right and that's how you break down
these barriers these technical itical
difficulties that you know I've been
very not easy to surmount to this point
and and and that's how we've managed to
literally build something so special
that we can literally deliver you what
we're showing thank you so much for
joining us and talking to us about
watchdogs Legion when can people play it
so right now we have it we have a
feeling Emma that they can consume in
our booth and see it played live for
them and the game is out from like 6
2020 thank you so much thank you very
much it was a pleasure and if you're
watching at home make sure don't go
anywhere we'll be right back with apex
legends season 2 and yes we're gonna be
talking about that new character what's
in it
[Music]
you